Shakira breaks her silence on a number
of topics including her split from
longtime partner Gerard PK and those tax
fraud allegations there's a lot on my
plate at the moment this singer covers
Elle's October issue inside she candidly
addresses her relationship with the
Soccer Star which ended in June after 12
years together they share two kids
nine-year-old Milan and seven-year-old
Sasha they're the Center of My Universe
and my biggest priority in life talking
about their separation Shakira says
quote I'm still going through it and
because I'm in the public eye and
because our separation is not like a
regular separation and so it's been
tough not only for me but also for my
kids incredibly difficult amid the drama
Shakira says her number one mission in
life is to protect their kids I never
thought I would say this music is my
hobby yeah
and but you know what
they they switch the dynamic completely
and while her relationship crumbled
another tragedy the singer's father
battling health issues in the ICU
Shakira calls it quote The Darkest Hour
of my life
the Colombian star also tells the mag
about the sacrifice she made during
their 12-year romance uprooting her life
to Gerard's country Spain so he could
focus on his soccer career try to live a
normal life we try to bring normal
normalcy to the lives of our kids
because we think that that's so
important so we go to supermarkets and
we go to the movies and we try to do the
stuff that every family would do because
they deserve it but it's not easy I
gotta tell you and living in Spain has
now proven to come with its own set of
complications in July Shakira was hit
with a six count indictment accusing her
of failing to pay the Spanish government
about 15 million dollars in taxes
between 2012 and 2014. prosecutors in
Spain want Shakira to serve over eight
years in prison and pay over 20 million
in fines if she's convicted but Shakira
insists she's completely innocent quote
I've paid every thing they claimed I
owed even before they filed a lawsuit so
as of today I owe zero to them but even
during a time when it feels like all
dark clouds Shakira is focusing on what
she does best music yeah the singer is
hard at work on her first album since
2017 calling it a therapeutic experience
biggest hit today no idea I think
probably it's all night
I'm starting to feel this way or
whenever whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
she didn't share when the new records
coming out but we did get a taste of
what's to come with her most recent
single with the black eyed peas and
David Guetta
[Music]
plus not just music Shakira's also been
busy making TV on her NBC competition
series Dancing with Myself
you sure you're from Jersey you're not
from Colombia I think it's a show for
everybody
um not not only for professionals most
of the contestants who participate
aren't I mean virtuosos or or
um
Specialists they just enjoy dancing and
they want to share their passion for it
and they want to express themselves well
Shakira we can't wait for you to share
your passion with us and your new album
whenever wherever it drops
[Music]